kelly ripa makes us all want to
immediately hire a personal trainer the
live with Kelly and Ryan co-host
instagrams this sexy candid photo on
Tuesday snapped by none other than her
very own daughter Lola you could have
fooled us in the pic the mom of three
can be seen adjusting her embroidered
cover up while standing on the beach in
a white bikini her blonde beachy waves
are total perfection and would you check
out those killer stems the 48 year old
star tagged her eighteen year old
daughter in the post along with the
caption sulla Soleil avec hashtag Papa
the French saying translates to under
the Sun with hashtag Papa Kelly and her
families seem to be enjoying a tropical
getaway and based on her captions we're
thinking they're somewhere in France
here's a look at Ripa's IG stories
photoshoot with hubby Mark Consuelos
complete with another French caption
more than we like each other but
meanwhile mark instagrammed a series of
snaps from their trip along with this
shot with their oldest son michael ET
spoke with the mom and dad of three last
week at the trevor life gala where they
opened up about what they're looking
forward to most when all of their kids
move out in addition to 22 year old
Michael and 18 year old Lola the duo are
also parents to 16 year old Joaquin we
are down to one kid and by the way he's
in Vancouver so I'm truly going to be
running through the house naked I just
want everybody to know that I'm gonna be
sitting on every piece of furniture
naked be warned before you come over
that's what I'll be doing in my spare
and you're welcome America no doubt Ripa
and her hubby will be enjoying that
private time just last week Kelly
revealed to our live audience that Lola
walked in on her and Mark having sex on
her 18th birthday
shut the door you hear you just ruined
my birthday
life and I use this in color and now
everything is great
is Lola okay today how is she feeling
traumatized by name that we saved the
birthday cake for tonight yeah wasn't
hungry yesterday yesterday she lost her
appetite it was half off there is no
spike she's fine she'll make it
I mean you know these are good it's the
circle of life
[Music]